I said I'm Ali Khan greetings of peace
now I want you to imagine going to a
place that you've read about stories
that you've heard about coming to life
now for instance where jesus prayed the
Garden of Gethsemane where Abraham and
his son put up the walls to the one of
the holiest mosques my sugar duck saw
and all the other prophets that you've
heard about in the Bible and in the
Quran and now it's all over the news
this is that place in Jerusalem now I
have a friend who just came back from
there and he's gonna share after going
through the 13 plus checkpoints it
seemed like certain people don't want
people there so they have a system of
roadblocks set up he got through all
those checkpoints and all those
roadblocks and he just came from being
on the scene where it's heated up over
there why has it heated up so much why
do Muslims have such a strong connection
to this place all that more and his
story that he has to share from his
exciting visit to Jerusalem when we come
back with my next guest we are going to
the Garden of Gethsemane over here
apparently according to the Bible the
New Testament Matthew 26 verse 39
prophet Jesus peace be upon him he
prayed to God that he prayed to God for
being saved and he said that not my will
but your will so how can Jesus be God
when he was praying to God and actually
he was doing the sajda
he was doing the salute when he was
praying to God
so this is a big evidence that Jesus was
a messenger just like the Quran
proclaims and his message was the
message to call people to worship the
creator and not the creation so these
trees are apparently from the time of
Prophet Jesus peace be upon him and
let's take a look
[Music]
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahu birkut
peace and blessings be upon you
everybody out there you coming here to
the deen show we got a lot to talk about
today with my friend who just came dr.
Sabeel you just came back you were
actually the day before you ended up
there in Jerusalem while some while
Trump the whole thing was going on with
the the paperwork being signed to
efficiently recognized Jerusalem as the
state the capital for Israel and you
were actually there you were on the
ground we got a lot to talk about a lot
people are excited I want to know what I
mean you were on the ground is that
right alhamdulillah
well everyone assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuhu so last week
I was in Jerusalem I was there when the
whole commotion about mr. Trump's
signing the agreement to make Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel so I was like
really tense should we go there or
should I just avoid going there but then
I realized that you know all throughout
my life I was hearing same thing with
you about all of those historical sites
about all the significance of Jerusalem
within the Islamic theology and I was
thinking that if I do not go there and
if things get more difficult for the
Muslims to go there I may miss this
golden opportunity so for that reason me
and my two brothers we took a chance we
went up there and alhamdulillah it was a
priceless experience brother Eddie we
are we want people want to know like
what because this is why is this so
you're going planning this trip most
people don't know how dear this is
right this is where you have the birth
of Jesus peace be upon them this is
where you have so much history this is
like one of the of the three holy
mosques that Muslims can go with the
intention to go visit right so you were
making that trip and you know people are
are wondering why why is this so dear to
Muslims right why is this something that
the whole Muslim world now is is pretty
much it's not a Palestinian thing it's
this is a Muslim thing yeah it's really
important for us the Muslims to know
specially and also when non-muslim
friends our neighbors our colleagues to
know that what is the significance of
Jerusalem and Palestine for the Muslims
and it's not just for the Muslims by the
way in the the 1.7 billion Muslims yes
it's near and dear to us but for the 2.2
billion Christians it's as much
significance also for them inshaallah
and we are going to touch upon their
topic so for the muslims is really
important that Jerusalem was a very
first Hitler for the Muslims you know
from the year 610 when the wahi the
revelation came to Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him up until the time up
until the years 624 for about 13 long
years that was the direction in which
Muhammad peace be upon him and the
Companions when they were in Makkah they
used to pray towards that area towards
Jerusalem before the Kaaba before the
cover because the Kaaba was surrounded
by all the idols or so yeah so until
they were purified Muslims used to face
Jerusalem in prayer in prayer yes the
prayers so there's one important reason
second important reason as it says in
the Quran chapter number 17 surah al
Asiri
ayah number one and just the translation
is Allah the exalted one
he had Muhammad peace be upon him go
from the magical harem Majesta Makkah
and to vital Mohandas majid al aqsa in
the in the night journey which I was
which was a miracle as journey by the
way from Makkah to Jerusalem and from
there he prayed with the
with many many prophets and then he went
to the seven heavens and he met many
many different prophets so for that
reason it is also really important the
second the third reason it's important
is because when we read the Quran there
are many many prophets and messengers
mentioned in there about twenty five by
name and many thousands came by the way
before their time
all throughout the world so many of
those prophets and messengers they lived
there they preached there and they
invited people to Islam to the message
of one God in that land so there's the
number three important reason for the
Muslims number four important reason is
many of the companions of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him when they
went out for the sake of sharing the
message of Islam when they went out to
fight many many defensive battles with
the Romans the portions are different
people some of them they were buried in
those very blessed places so for any and
all of these reasons it's not just a
Palestinian issue by the way it's not an
issue of the Palestinian land you know
giving justice to them yes there's
important but first and foremost it is
important for all this 1.7 billion
Muslims and 2.2 billion Christians
around the world
so all those prophets now Moses Jesus
problem and peace and must be upon him
pretty much many of the the prophets
that I mentioned in the Bible that area
around that area this is where many of
them they took up the call from from
Allah from the Creator wasn't this also
built up the walls are raised up by
Abraham and his Hawk his son is this
correct and these are all where we would
say Muslims right they were all
believers in one God they were all the
ones who submitted to the will of God
they were Muslims yes of course the
Quran mentions a nam in surah 3 chapter
number 3 verse number 84 where it
mentions that Muslims we believe in all
of these prophets then it mentions is
chapter number 42 verse number 13 that
the same message means the message of
monotheism given to you ma
let peace be upon him was also given to
know how and Abraham and Moses and to
Jesus peace be upon all of them so you
know when I went up there you know just
like you we have been reading about all
of these historical places the Quran is
full of the stories and the message and
the miracles of these prophets but
actually when you went when you go there
when you travel the same streets as
those noble companions and the prophets
of the past they went through the
challenges that they may have gone
through some of the historical places
that they have visited and they have
preached from so once you go there
actually the Quran comes alive and that
feeling is so priceless by the way the
stories in the Quran now it's kind of
visual it gives you a visual it really
hits home you know when ibrahim
alaih-is-salaam he had two sons yeah is
he smiling
Shefali salaam so actually the grave of
ismail allah salla the grave of ibrahim
al salam is there right and then the
grave of luteal a salam and no anually
salaam and different prophets and the
message all in that area right there in
that area and also somewhat in the area
of Jordan too by the way and some of the
companions of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him their graves is there so that
also hits us if Islam was restarted in
Makkah in Madina what are these
companions doing in those faraway places
like in Jordan in Syria and Lebanon and
Jerusalem and a Philistine what are they
doing up there why did they travel there
and it finally hits you that they
weren't there because they want to
invite humanity to the worship of one
God with all the sacrifices and the
tortures and sacrificing of their life
some of them they went there with the
noble mission of sharing la ilaha
illallah muhammadur rasulullah means
there is no one to worship besides Allah
and Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah
so there is a really big lesson for me
specially when I went there you know
it's not just about visiting the
historical sites and taking the videos
and the in the photos and taking some
selfies right there's not it by the way
but the biggest lesson
Allah subhana Allah has given us some
mission they fulfilled it the prophets
and the noble companions now the ball is
in our coat
are we going to take up the challenge
and fulfill the mission and that is the
biggest lesson that I learned now your
tour guide was a Christian actually you
talk right you're the one you had a tour
guide yes yes yes tell us about this
experience and what some of the sites
that you visit when you got there what
was the first thing now that you saw did
you see because on the news you're
seeing you know a lot of protests and
there's a lot of things going on what
are you seeing now on the ground well
the very first thing that we encountered
as we crossed or when we went to the
border of Jordan and Palestine were the
security guards with the dogs with the
guns drawn at you right in your face the
check the passport they asked many many
questions alhamdulillah I came back
alive I'm here right so alhamdulillah
despite all the challenges you know 13
14 15 checkpoints by the way all
throughout harassment and dogs checking
you and emptying your pockets not of
questions not once twice three times
four times five times six times seven
times eight nine times to avoid 11 12 13
maybe 14 15 times that many checkpoints
by the way Wow but the bottom line is
they our challenge is going up there
even when we went to the Masjid al-aqsa
they were many many soldiers they slyly
soldiers up there with guns drawn they
want to know are we Muslims they only
let the Muslims inside by the way
because of the sacredness of the place
so we also had to go through there and
then there were some some other security
who wants us to recite the Shahada
before we go there right and we did just
to prove that we are Muslims yeah yeah
so that that's that's pretty much that's
the declaration of faith that there's
nothing worthy of worship because of the
crater the heavens and earth and
Mohammed is the final messenger so they
make you say this Shahada yes yes yeah
it was funny but this made us aide but
there's a form of Dawa from us to them
in sha Allah so in the day of judgment
they cannot they cannot have the
plain that no one mentioned to them
about the sha la ilaha illallah
muhammadan here in a day in and day out
give them here I mean you know as
Muslims that's what we can do you know
we pray for the people even those people
who are oppressing us there's for the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
taught us by the way
yes what's the condition of the the
people there now on the ground Muslims
and and what's the what do you what do
you what are you seeing for yourself you
know we don't hear you don't hear much
you have to go to independent news
sources you don't really hear on
mainstream media the circumstances that
are affecting the people who are
actually living there the oppression
that they're going through it is pretty
sad going there so the land of Palestine
Palestine is divided into the the the
Jewish sectors and then the Muslim and
the Christian sectors combined as I
mentioned before our guide was a was a
Christian brother so he had as much
sentiments against the occupation as we
do by the way the Christian yes yeah
yeah so Christians are being also
pressed they're also on during the same
conditions as much oppressed as the
Muslims but of the Christians for
example in the Jewish sectors you have
fresh water 24/7 they have big pots and
big buildings that the roads are called
okay you know nicely furnished but in
the Muslim sectors and the Christian
sectors lack of playgrounds lack of
water resources you know lack of hygiene
the roads are just desecrated they don't
have the they cannot buy new property in
the East Jerusalem the one word that
comes to my mind that describes the
condition of our Palestinian brothers
and they slyly and the Christian
Brothers that what would with this
brother Eddie and I cannot deny that I
cannot deny that apartheid apartheid you
know when we hear about apartheid that
happen in South Africa with all the
racism the oppression in the killing and
the tortures that happen to the African
American not african-american
African brothers and sisters up there we
hear this stories but by going to
Palestine actually watching what's going
on and there's the one word that comes
to my mind and I have to be honest by
the way you know our fellow Americans
over here we are supporting by three
billion dollars plus how much 3 billion
3 million let's add three more zeros to
the 3 million 3 billion 3 billion and
there's mine and your house how often is
that 3 annually annually every year
every billion 3 billion right in the
last 20 years is like 80 billion dollars
of yours and mine taxpaying dollars to
support the oppression which is going on
to human beings
let's not just call them Palestinians or
the Christians these are our human
brothers and sisters in humanity by the
way so if oppression is going on Islam
dictates to me and you that we have to
speak out we have to put them on the
radar of the world so people can
actually see that what are we supporting
up there so it's really important for us
to take that into perspective that the
realities are on the ground are totally
different than what the media shows you
know what the media shows is that there
is a democracy which is Israel
surrounded by all these dictators that
not that is not even close to it by the
way the Palestinian Muslims and the
Palestinian Christians they are treated
as second-class citizens of their you
know when we were traveling our tour
guide was traveling from city to city
from her Braun to West Bank in different
places on the mountains and different
lands he showed to us you know these
buildings that you see up there
this high-rises that you see up there
this lavish apartments and buildings up
there these are the settlers the Jewish
settlers by force they took the
Palestinian lands and these are
supported by the Israeli army by the
Israeli regime and that's what we are
supporting unfortunately yeah this is
this this is the same thing I mean you
have a mmm and I recommend people to
watch you know just
look up people like me copilot I've had
him on the program
it's my Israelis Israelis my friend he's
a Jewish Israeli activists who has a
book called the general son and he
strongly advocates for truth he's out
there educating the people on exactly
what you're saying and that's not
because it's one thing coming from a
Muslim but now coming from an Israeli
Jewish man and not only that but someone
like him whose father who's was a
general in the Israeli army and his
great-grandfather was a signer of the
Declaration of Independence and he comes
out and he's letting the people know of
the unjust oppression that's going on in
this part of the world now one more one
more observation by the Eddy which I
made up there you know in many of the
checkpoints by the way these are just
these are this white Caucasian soldiers
indice wryly we dresses and I was
thinking where did this Americans came
from and then I asked a tour guide who
are these people they look like white
blond hair blue eyes people and his
rallies are not like that and he told me
that these are Americans these are our
American youth who went up there to
support this regime so they have the
dual Passport so for them to retain the
Israeli passport they have to serve the
boys have to serve the guys have to
serve three years and the girls have to
serve two years in the military in the
military some air compression Americans
and that's what we are supporting with
our taxpaying dollars three billion
dollars which can be used over here the
better our schools to fight the drugs
and the racism and the uninsured people
three billion dollars is too much when
we bring the money over here a lot of
our problems in the USA would be solved
in China what do you think about there's
a there's a tweet by a well-known MP
it's like a congressman senator day in
Britain he says that Zionism is not
Judaism Judaism is not a religion not a
race many Jews are not Zionists most
Zionists are not
Jews many Zionists hate Jews opposition
to Israel is not anti-semitism because
many people when you bring up this this
subject nothing almost sums hate Jews
when you hear something like that and
what is your response to someone who
might say something like that some
ignorant like that you know
unfortunately there's a popular notion
out there in the media social media or
so that Muslims hate the Jews or Islam
is against the Jewish people there's
nothing nothing but the truth by the way
right that the truth is in the Quran
there are no less than 30 plus places
where Quran has honored the Jewish and
the Christian people by the title of
people of the book correct people of the
book with honor because revelation was
given to them many prophets were sent to
them and V Muslims we recognize the
people of the book which is the Jewish
and the Christian people number one
number two when prophet muhammad peace
be upon him when he moved from Makkah to
Madinah in the year 6:23 they were a big
Jewish community out there you know if
the Prophet hated the Jews he would have
expelled them tortured them and just
took away their rights but that's not
what he did
so let's hear from David Warren Steen
professor David Bornstein right
he's the Jewish professor specializing
in this topic in the year 2012 in the
Jewish Journal calm the Jaycee calm he
wrote the title of the article was what
did the Muslims do to the Jews and the
very first sentence he wrote there is
Islam saved the jury that's a big
statement by the way and then he
explained he mentioned two points this
is a Jewish professor now it's a journey
sir yeah academic professor right and
he's saying that there are two two times
at least in the history that Islam cave
came to help Judaism from it getting
destroyed by the Christian Roman Empire
and by the portion Empire and this is
what he said the Jewish people were
preyed upon all over
the world specially in the Middle East
so muhammad peace be upon him when he
moved from Makkah to Madinah he wrote
the very first constitution of the world
called as the Medina Charter what the
Medina Charter says so this is before
the Geneva Conventions the French
Constitution and the US Constitution in
the Geneva in the Medina Charter it says
that the Jewish people the Muslim people
and the Jewish people would be one
people they would have autonomy they
would have freedom of to choose their
religion have their synagogues and their
culture their penal system their justice
system so they were protected they were
given identity and they were given a
safe haven within the Muslim land and
that is Islam by the way if Muslims
hated the Jews the Prophet would have
dispelled them right away
Yeah right number two all throughout
history you know when we look at so
David Warren Steen he also said when the
Spanish Inquisition was going on about
500 or so years ago in Spain the
Christians were torturing the Muslims
and the Jewish people some of them were
forcefully converted some of them were
burned at the stake at that point the
Jewish people did not had anywhere to
run except the Muslim land in North
Africa in Turkey and yes in Palestine we
open our hearts and doors to them he
welcomed them we gave them the
protection and we gave them the home we
don't hate the Jewish people when the
World War 2 happened by the way you know
the Nazi Germany Hitler and his people
they were torturing they were they were
requesting the different governments in
Europe to hand over the Jewish people
it made the Muslim country of Albania
and Turkey and also Iran by the way they
literally protected 100,000 Jewish
people from get them getting killed by
the Nazi Germany so the bottom line is
we don't hate the Jewish people but
those of them who are going to extreme
to have the occupation join us Zionists
for taking away the rights of the human
beings both the
Christians and the Muslim Palestinians
many of them I believe are hiding behind
the religion of Judaism many of them
because you have a lot of I've had rabbi
Weiss on the program and he talks about
how this goes actually against the Torah
of what they have today he talks about
how this is actually there the Orthodox
Jews and and many who were involved you
know in the persecution during the time
of Hitler they didn't actually they
protested the State of Israel and they
also many of them are getting beat down
these Orthodox Jews there's also
speaking out against this the Zionism
yeah so this is is there this is
different difference here between you
know many of the what when we say
because many giant scientists are just
many nationalists they don't have
anything atheist secular circulars I
don't really but you know believe in God
or no just more nationalism you know
when you touched upon the Bible by the
way you know is there a historical basis
for them you know to have monopoly on
Jerusalem none at all
I will give you maybe one or two
references if you go to the Old
Testament and the Jews and the
Christians they both believe in this in
the very first book of the Old Testament
the seventeenth chapter verse number
three it says it says about how that
land and how the blessings should be
there coming from God to all the
descendants of Prophet Abraham peace be
upon him and as we know that he
initially had two sons
it's my laila salaam and Ishaaq
alehsalaam right ishmael and isaac as
they say peace be upon them so this
blessing is there for both of them
number one number two when you look at
the Genesis chapter 21 verse number 13
it mentions exactly the same thing yes
there are some prophecies for the
descendants of Yaffa lisanna and then
there are prophecies for the descendants
of Ishmael Islam and which would be the
Muslims as we know or the Arabs
yeah so the land belongs to both by the
way the blessings is for both and the
prophecies coming from God in their own
Bible is for both people not just for
the Jewish people but also for the
Muslims the descendants from Asia from
its model Islam
now you also you visited this church of
nativity can you talk about this what
you saw there and sure sure experience
so one of the places around Jerusalem is
the Church of Nativity so that church
apparently is built upon the site where
prophet Jesus peace be upon him he was
born because nativity this word what is
this for people who never heard this
what does that mean actually I mean what
does that translate it to birth of Jesus
oh it's like the native place of Jesus
perhaps right yeah so but the bigger
thing is that there's where he was born
apparently according to the Christian
traditions so they have a place up there
the actual spot where he where he was
born and people were actually going
there and they were prostrating but the
biggest but we do like Muslims
prostrating you have it like we do right
but a bigger question that's like Jesus
yeah I will come to that right
but a bigger question that should come
to the mind off of our fellow Christians
would be how can Jesus be God when he
was born right it's like an aha moment
now it's a hot moment right I mean God
is always eternal God is does not bar he
does not beget now his bee-garden as the
Quran says in Chapter surah number one
one two so that itself should be a red
flag for thinking Christians God is
always eternal he's neither born he
doesn't die by the way right but people
are just going there they are just
trying to adorn that place and
prostrating up there they're singing and
not dancing back away singing going on
and there were churches of different
denominations up there but the quran
mentions about jesus his birth in
chapter number 19 verse number 30 there
may be the mother of Jesus
you know regards peace be on both of
them when she brought the baby Jesus the
Jewish people they started to accuse her
saying that
how can you do such a thing you know
fornication adultery how can you do such
a thing and how can she prove ourselves
right she pointed to the baby Jesus and
the baby Jesus he started to speak
saying that I am a servant of God I am
appointed as a prophet of God I am given
the Torah my message is the message of
oneness of God so that is the true story
of baby Jesus and then as you mentioned
I also went to a place which is called
as the Garden of Gethsemane where Jesus
was praying now so no what happened is
according to the gospel stories
especially the Gospel of Matthew the
first gospel in the New Testament you
were there that story that's mentioned
there yes I was I was looking at the
actual place where the Christians say
that Jesus went there right yeah so as
the Jewish and the Roman people were
coming after Jesus he went away to a far
place called the Garden of Gethsemane
over there he prostrated himself on the
ground and he's praying to God you were
there I was there I mean I was not there
2,000 years ago but I saw the place
right yeah the actual trees the olive
the the actual trees in the garden is
still there still there by the from
2,000 years ago so he prayed to God so
it says in the Bible Matthew chapter 26
verse number 39 so he was praying to God
Jesus was praying to God prostrating
forehead on the ground saying that Oh
God take this cup of death away from me
not my will but your will so if this is
narrated to you brother Eddie what
should come to your mind by the way
Jesus praying to God what questions come
to your mind yeah a bunch of who is he
praying to my will not yours that mean
that someone is all-powerful above him
Islam fits that description because
Islam means to your will submit your
will to God yes all of them but even a
bigger question right you know according
to the Trinitarian Christians Jesus is
God
does God need to pray to some other God
yeah why is he praying does God have a
God but people will say what about so
he's teaching us how to pray well then
he can send a revelation to the prophets
you know just like God send revelation
to Muhammad peace be upon him and he
showed us how to pray so really
important you know God does not pray to
God but Jesus was praying to God so he
cannot be God he was praying the way
that Muslims pray that means he was a
Muslim and he was saying that not my
will but your will means anyone who
submits their will to the will of God
what do we call that person a Muslim a
Muslim so even in the Bible - by the way
he's called as a prophet of God many
many times one reference would be from
Matthew chapter 13 verse number 57 mark
chapter 6 verse number 4 Luke 33 verse
Luke 13 verse 33 and john 444 so these
are all the places where jesus is
mentioned as a prophet of god a man
approved by God amen approved by God you
know it says that in the Bible a man
approved by God yes he's also called a
messenger passage chapter 2 verse number
22 alright he did science and miracles
by the power of God and that's what the
quran says yeah
but the biggest thing about prophet
Jesus peace be upon him both from the
Bible and from the Quran is you know
according to the Bible Mark chapter 12
verse number 29 person came to Jesus to
ask him a question that of all the
different commandments which one is the
first the greatest of all the
commandments and as you know the Jewish
people have 613 commandments lot of
Commandments right so this person wants
to know which is the greatest of all of
them so Jesus as a Messenger of God he
replied mark chapter 12 verse number 29
he said here o Israel the Lord our God
is only one worship him not him right
worship him with all your heart mind
soul and strength and that is the first
commandment hmm as a messenger of God
he's showing to
people that he alone God alone is to be
worship not Jesus not Holy Ghost but
only one God and there is the main
message of Prophet Jesus peace be upon
ya this is something that many of our
friends our brothers and humanity
Christians struggle with even those
Orthodox
you know when on the the third caliph
Omar read a long line when he came and
the Christians didn't want to give and
this is another really significant part
of history that's in there in the books
there and historical references that
they're Christians dating because they
knew the justice of the Muslims so they
didn't want to give the the keys right
over to anyone but the ruler and then
Omar as you know he came and he
obviously from there he established that
they wanted him to pray in the church he
refused to pray in the church why
because he didn't want their church to
be taken away later you know the church
did you see that sure yes yeah you know
their churches you know that key still
belongs to the Muslim uh-huh you know
each single day when the church has to
be opened for their services it's not a
Catholic person who opens it nor a
Protestant Marmon Jehovah's Witness it
is a Muslim who comes there with a key
and he opens that historical church yeah
for the questions he could have taken
the church he could have prayed there
and then today they would have taken the
church no he didn't do that you know so
that again shows the respect the
respects to the people of the book to
the minorities how Islam came to protect
them not to take away the rights and
then the the the other point I wanted to
make was many of the Orthodox Greek
Christians at that time and many others
they flopped to Islam because they also
they connected with this message of the
worship of the One God and Jesus being a
Messenger of God yes yeah and they ended
up accepting Islam at this time yes you
know so it says in the Quran the message
of Jesus according to the [ __ ]
chapter 3 verse number 51 in the la hora
beaver abu qamha boudu has a Sarah
Thomas terpene so Jesus Christ is saying
that verily Allah God is my Lord and
your Lord worship Him alone and that is
the straight path mm-hmm so you got to
see this over almost out of time a few
more things that I want to I want to
cover that there was a you mentioned
something about a statue of statue and
prostration what was the statue of the
Garden of Gethsemane yeah that's where
Jesus peace be upon her statue of him
yeah there's a statue of him even though
the Bible says he placed his forehead on
the ground what the Christians they have
done in the statue they made him just
lying on a big stone right they did not
actually show the prostration the way
that Muslims prayed Jesus was praying
the same way yeah but in the in the
actual image that they have it there
he's still praying by the way resting
his hands on some stone but not in the
full prostration let me ask you this
doesn't that because you're making a
statue when you look at the tirana me
and you look at many other passages in
the Bible it says thou shall not I mean
it's the first command thou shalt not
make any graven images in the heavens
and earth and worship these you see the
opposite happening I mean it says in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter five verse
number 16 and Exodus chapter 3 verse
number 20 the very first commandment is
that worshiping God and then it follows
that do not make any graven images
nothing in the nothing in the heavens
nothing in the sea yeah no graven images
but unfortunately our Christian brothers
and sisters their images of Jesus images
of the saints image so many images up
there they're going away the very first
commandment unfortunately yeah that's
why it's so important that they hear
this message of Islam and it resonates
because it connects you know it connects
with the true message of all the
prophets some people now an extreme
group are trying to and we'll close with
this let's talk about this for a second
they call it
there's the rapture and they're actually
trying to put all of these things in
with now the recognizing Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel kind of forcing
all of this that the second coming of
Jesus and now with the hopes that they
believe the Jews will end up accepting
him becoming Christian and all these
events that they're trying to force to
happen and now you see the escalation
where we're headed you know it's quite a
funny by the way
I mean it's not funny it's pretty sad
that the Jewish people they're not
realizing why the evangelical Christians
they are supporting the State of Israel
the biblical prophecies by the way both
Old Testament especially the New
Testaments Luke the Gospel of Luke comes
to my mind in the Gospel of Luke it
mentions that in the second coming of
prophet Jesus peace be upon him that's
when he is going to have the unbelievers
in Jesus to be brought in front of him
so they can be slayed
so the non-christians the non-believers
of Issa listen on would be slayed then
there would be a 1000 years of reign by
Jesus peace be upon him and by the
Christians all over the world and then
the war of the big war would he come
again yes that war would happen and then
there would be a rapture the Christians
would be lifted up all of this need to
happen but the very first thing would be
the Jewish Kingdom or the Israeli state
needs to be formed and the Jewish have
to congregate in one place but they
don't realize our Jewish friends is that
once those things happen the prophecies
the calamity will come on the Jewish
people they will be the one either
forcefully converted or exterminated
right so when you look at the bigger
picture the best thing would be to give
human rights to all the people doesn't
matter Jews Muslims and Christians and
that's what islam teaches yeah so
overall how did the trip end now at the
end so you were there how long a week I
was there for a week
hamdullah right but one message that I
would like to have to over Muslim
brothers and sisters and also for our
all the listeners by the way again as I
mention it's not about going
to the trip and taking the photos with
the Dome of the rock and praying in the
Masjid al-aqsa visiting historical
places the most important lesson for me
brother Eddie is that when I go there
and visit the graves of all of these
noble companions of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him like Xia Bing Haritha
like you know Abdullah of the Ryman even
raouf Jabbar even with a lip Jaffer
without when I go and visit their places
their graves what hits to my mind is
that they could have lived in Makkah in
Madina but they went up there to convey
the message of Islam we are like why
sent by Allah subhana Allah to this part
of the world and our biggest obligation
here besides doing justice to the wall
and relief efforts and humanitarian
efforts raising families having job the
biggest mission that we have over here
is to invite humanity to worship on God
because Allah Kaja alaykum o motton
versatile otaku new Shahada
Alanna's willya Kuna our Rasool o
alaikum Shaheed on surah baqara surah 2
ayah number 143
speaking to the Muslims Allah subhana
Allah says that all Muslims I have made
you into a nation the Allah subhana
Allah saying that I have made you into a
just nation a balanced nation that you
become witnesses to humanity the way the
messenger of allah was a witness over
you so message to over non-muslims is
that islam the faith of all the prophets
they are all proclaim the message of one
god a message to the muslims no new
prophet is to come that responsibility
now falls under the shoulder of all of
us so may Allah make it easy for all of
us so we live by giving peace and
justice to all of humanity and we and we
convey and become peace ambassadors of
Islam to all of humanity
I mean how about a thank you to trump
waking up the Muslims is that a good
good thing waking up the sleeping
Muslims missing father
now coming you know to the mustards and
now maybe he's uh he's hit some buttons
and they're waking up honey turn to turn
back to their Dean anything that happens
there is a purpose in it but we Muslims
need to grab the opportunity by the way
as we did the show like a few weeks ago
I mentioned in there that the 2017 is
the best year for Dawa in the USA with
all the different statistics by the way
so let's not miss this opportunity let's
come together as United Muslim Ummah and
become peace ambassadors of Islam to
humanity thank you very much for sharing
your trip and experiences with us all
right we covered a lot hopefully you can
take a great message from this the love
that Muslims have for Jesus the love
that Muslims have for one of the holiest
sites in the world Jerusalem our
attachment there the history there and
the different the difference between now
the many of the misconceptions that
Muslims and this propaganda between
Muslims and Jews that was cleared up so
there was a lot of beneficial things
here now what are you gonna do as a
Muslim now are you just gonna get all
emotional in protests and ahahah and
then you know and all that is the
fizzles out or you gonna start coming
back to your Deen
are you gonna start to for the people
that are in the Deen are you gonna start
sharing the Deen right there's so much
history there and dr. Seville he hit hit
at home when he was there all of they
came alive it came alive from now from
him reading the Quran visiting this part
of the world and now will it come alive
in your life that's what it's supposed
to do the Quran is supposed to be a book
that you live that you implement and
that you share because you care and I
hope that this was a benefit we'll see
you next time here in the D show
subscribe if you haven't already peace
Salaam alaikum